how does one
gauge their their progress like I've
found that often it's others who are the
more reliable effective mirrors of of
one's personal growth because on a
day-to-day basis it's hard to really
know that within yourself how does one
know when they're they're moving in the
right direction or you know is there is
there
a situation in which you've arrived at
at a place of of well-being or is this
just layer after layer until you know
yeah expire
okay
I've been out in 40 years yeah you're
still finding parts that need to be
healed but
um to answer your question
I don't get triggered like I used to by
so many things so some of how you can
judge it is
are the same things triggering me and
it's just not the case anymore
so that's one measure